[Music]
thank you very much for having me
um so today we're going to be talking
about teaching our online with our
studio cloud
and the link to the slides is here on
the first slide and you'll be able to
see it on the footer of most of the
slides that i'll be going through
um that goes to the rendered slides and
i'm not going to be showing much code
today or any at all actually we're going
to be talking about how to set up our
studio cloud for your teaching
but if you're interested in the source
files i'd be happy to provide a link to
that as well
so let's get started the first question
i'd like to answer is
why might you be interested in using
rstudio
in the cloud there are a few reasons
um first one is how do your students get
started when they're starting to learn r
so here is one recipe you can get your
students
to install r our studio install a bunch
of packages that you're going to use for
that lesson or for the
entire duration of your course load the
packages
if you're using version control they
need to also make sure
git is installed and this list could
keep going if you're teaching anything
beyond an introductory course
this produces every single bullet point
here produces a friction point
especially if you're working with an
audience that is new to r on the other
hand
here's another alternative go to your
browser
go to this link and log in and the
environment is already set up for you so
this is much less friction to begin with
another reason though is maybe you used
to be teaching in a setup like this
and now your students are in their own
bedrooms
and uh signing on individually so you no
longer
have neither do you have control over
what's on their computer necessarily
because it's not a computer lab
that maybe you've worked with your
university it to set up
but also you don't get to look over
their shoulder anymore
maybe you're teaching remotely at this
point um
and so we're going to be touching on a
few things that our studio cloud
makes easier as you're teaching remotely
as well
all right so how do we get our studio in
the cloud
we have a couple options again one
option is an option that our studio has
been providing
pretty much forever i would say is our
studio server pro
so what is our studio server pro this is
a piece of software
that if you have these following things
you can get running with
you either yourself as the instructor
needs this admin experience
or support from your it you also need
either hardware to install the software
on or a local virtual machine setup
or some sort of cloud computing credit
and each one of these
is basically cost points as you can
imagine both the support and also
the hardware or wherever you're going to
be doing your compute
in addition to that you yourself
probably have some our studio experience
if you have all of these this might be
the right option for you
however if you're having to shift your
teaching
mid-semester quickly without much notice
even if you have
much of these uh happening this may not
necessarily be the right time to be
undertaking
something that takes multiple steps to
set up but i wanted to leave this here
on this slide and also
have a link to the rcd academic pricing
which basically says that if you are
using the software for teaching purposes
you can freely license it
the whole package itself doesn't end up
being free somebody's paying for the it
support time somebody's paying for
compute
but ultimately the software itself is
free and you can get your students
on to these this machine and the r
studio instances and they're ready to
keep going
um just like i we said in the first
slide
alternatively if you're using our studio
cloud really the only thing you need
is our studio experience so you don't
need this as admin experience rit
support
and you don't actually need anything
related to compute either
so let's talk a little bit about our
studio cloud so we're not going to be
talking about the other option but we
are going to be talking about our studio
cloud today
our studio cloud was created to make it
easy for professionals hobbyists
trainers teachers and students to do
share
teach and learn data science using r
this is the mission of our studio cloud
and this is basically the sentence
you're going to find when you go to our
studio.cloud
um what does our studio cloud look like
if this is what the r studio id
looks like on your local machine this is
what our studio cloud looks like as you
can see
it looks exactly the same and that is
important if we are using this
to get your students started because you
don't want to be teaching them
in an environment where that experience
is not going to just carry
over to the local instance experience
the only difference is they're running
it in the browser
so it comes with a url to go to
why might you want why might you want to
use our studio cloud
over other options other ways of getting
our studio
in your web browser like our studio
server pro first of all it does not
require it support
which means that you don't need to
convince somebody else for their time
to help you with it get works out of the
box which is
i think a huge advantage if you're
teaching with version control
oftentimes what i hear is that if folks
are teaching with version control they
might be doing it not necessarily in an
intro course but in a more advanced
course
where they feel like students should be
able to go through the installation step
okay that might very well be
true installing rnr studio is not
too cumbersome to be perfectly honest
but getting git to work
on every single one of your students
machines in a local
install is not necessarily trivial
you can also knit to pdf and knit to
word which means that tech is installed
and word is installed
so if these are output options you use
with our markdown
um you already have those uh readily set
up for yourself as well
but additional to this it has a bunch of
features that are designed
specifically for instructors for example
your classes can be organized in
workspaces which means that if you're
running many classes it becomes a lot
easier to manage them
members can be assigned different roles
so you can have different permission
levels for instructors tas and students
your projects can be public or private
and you get to control that
for your students your projects can be
made into assignments
which makes it a lot easier for your
students to get started
your students can make copies of
projects so you can basically
set up projects up to a certain point
and ask your students to pick things up
from that point onwards
i think one of the most attractive
features is that you
as the instructor can peek into your
students project so we can actually
recreate that experience of looking over
your student's shoulder
even though you're not in the same room
with them and finally
a base project template can ensure that
you have the same packages
in each new project created in the
workspace so you no longer
should have a situation where you write
some code
and your student says they run the exact
same code but they're getting something
different from you
or a classmate when you get to our
studio cloud you can get started just
like this
and on the login window you can either
create an account or sign up with
something like google or github
or if you have a shiny apps at io
account that will also work as well
and you'll end into a blank slate like
this so there are two
things that you can see here there is
something called your workspace
and i usually like to think about your
workspace in the center as the sandbox i
play in
i rarely put teaching stuff there but
instead i
use separate workspaces for each one of
my classrooms
we will go through each one of these
options but generally as an instructor i
like keeping my
individual workspace as my sandbox for
trying things out or one-off sharing
and the individual workspaces for a
classroom
so workspaces when you create an account
on our studio cloud you get this
workspace of your own
you can add a new workspace and control
its permissions that's why i think it's
attractive option for setting up a class
and projects in either workspace either
the ones that you create specifically
for a class
or your own can be public or private so
you can use it as your own
or you can use it to share it with
people what is the project in our studio
cloud well
a new project in our studio cloud is
basically a new project in the r studio
ide
um i've met many people who have been
using rstudio for years and years but
don't necessarily use the project
features
i'm not necessarily going to be taking a
whole lot of time to describe why that's
beneficial but
even if you are using our studio your
local install
i strongly strongly recommend that you
use projects if you get nothing out of
this webinar but that
tip i think that will still be worth
your hour
trust me you won't regret it and if you
do want to learn more about why it is a
good idea to be using
our studio projects even in the local
ide i have a link to the relevant
section and the r for data science book
in the slides
similarly you can create projects from
git a git repository so a new project
from a git repository
in our studio cloud is the same thing as
creating a new project from git in the
rstudio ide
both of these actions clone a git
repository so you have two ways of
initiating a project
a blank slate or something that comes
from a git repository
when you're so we talked about these two
options you have your own workspace
or you can create classes these are your
two
options for sharing projects with
students we're going to start with the
simpler approach
although i will mention why i would
recommend this slightly more complicated
approach
option two but option one is you create
a single project and you share it with
your students
this is how easy it is it actually the
instructions fit into a tweet
so that's less than 280 characters go to
our studio.cloud login create a new
project
install any packages add any scripts or
markdown documents that you want to
share with your students
change the access level to be available
to everyone copy the url and share it
with your students
so going forward you're going to see
these two icons on my slides
one of them is for the teacher and the
other one is for the student
so i'll be walking you through some
views of what our studio cloud looks
like
um and we're going to be using these in
the bottom right corner of the slides to
see
are we looking at the teacher view or
are we looking at the student view
let's start with creating a new single
project
um so i'm going and creating a new
project
once the project is deployed what i can
do to start it
for uh to get it ready for my students
is i might for example choose to install
some packages that i'm going to be using
in whatever class example
or for the workshop that i am teaching
um
any of the packages that you install
will then be
uh available for your students as well
something i really like to do
is just create an our markdown document
quickly um
that will actually prompt the rcdo
instance to install any necessary
packages as well
i usually teach with our markdown
documents so i usually
place a template our markdown document
to get students started with
so if you knit this the file is going to
get
saved um which means that when your
students may
get their own copy of the project
they're going to be able to see that
file as well
you might want to rename the project
itself so that when you share it
students know
uh get inherit that name as well
and ultimately uh you want to share that
url with your students but by default
your projects are
available only to you so first you need
to change the access level
clicking on the gear icon and then you
can simply
send that url to your students
now let's look at the student view as to
how this looks
the student has received that url from
their instructor
they place it into their um
browser they log on and what they're
seeing
is that same project you can see with
the same name called workshop materials
but one thing that is different is that
it says temporary project on top so your
students need to remember
to save a permanent copy and what is
happening at this point
is a copy of the project is made for
them to further iterate on
if they forget to do that they lose
their changes but you can see that
they're able to get they got the same
document that you had created and in
fact if we try to just
load the tidy burst package which we had
previously installed
on the instructor side it loads meaning
that the install has
actually carried through
so pros and cons of sharing a signal
project like this
what's good about it is that students
land directly in
a project upon login which means they
get
they get the url from you and what they
see is our studio
and our studio ide and they can get
started
it works well for workshops where all
the work
that will be done completed is in a
single project
um but i don't think it works really
well where
you have where you're going to have a
much longer running class and you're
going to have a lot of work that you're
going
to be doing throughout the class or if
you want to track
students in some way it is also great
for sharing code in general so outside
of a teaching setting if you
want to do it for collaboration or to
create a replex one of the things i love
using this feature for is
represses for shiny apps that tend to be
sometimes
long um i have lots of code so you can
basically put it in an rcdo cloud
instance and share it with somebody else
for them to try it out
the not so good side is that remember
that
red reminder on top that's a temporary
project students need to remember to
make a copy of the project
and yes it's red and yes it's blinking
but people forget
and when i say students need to remember
really what i mean is you as the
instructor need to remind them
um so that places additional burden on
you as well because if they don't
and they work on it and then they close
out of their browser when they come back
they're not going to be able to see
their work
um another thing that's not so good is
that you can't keep track
of which students started their
assignments so they you share
the url with them and then it just goes
out into the ether you don't have a way
of seeing if a student
has derived a project from yours and
i'll be able to see that
show you the flip side of this when you
use the other paradigm
additionally if you are concerned about
students sharing work
this is not a great option because now
that a student
owns that project when they make a
copy of a non-temporary copy for
themselves
they now control the permissions of that
project which means they can simply
share it with another friend
and if this is an assignment where you
don't want students sharing code
now you've made it additionally easy for
them to do so
obviously um you controlling permissions
of a project
does not necessarily mean your students
aren't going to cheat if that's what
they really want to do
but i think as instructors uh it is
important for us
if we do want to follow certain rules
about sharing work
that we don't use a platform that makes
it too
easy for students to cheat
um on a remote teaching note i think one
of the things that makes it
hardest for sharing a single project is
that
you can't easily peek into student
projects
they would need to explicitly share the
project with you
i'm not sure why my bullet point is cut
off here but basically they need to set
the access level to be available to
everybody else and then
send the url to you as opposed to you
being able to track it much more easily
so i think that this idea of using our
studio cloud as a way of
peeking over your students shoulder to
help them with
any troubles that they're having does
not really apply when you share a single
project with them
the other option is to create a
workspace and get your students into
that workspace so when i think about
creating a workspace i think about i'm
building my classroom
and the people who are in uh invited in
here
are the people who are um in my class
either my students
or my helpers or tas
so how do we go about creating a
workspace and then sharing it with our
students so as an instructor
i click on new space on the sidebar give
a name for my new space
and also give it a description this is
the name and the description your
students will encounter
when you ultimately invite them to this
workspace
i create the workspace and then i'm
going to do a bunch of prep before i
actually invite my students in
so that's how easy it is to create the
workspace
um the next step is thinking about who
is going to be in the workspace so how
do i get
students into a class workspace there's
a tab called members
so if i click on that uh you can see
that
currently i myself is the only person in
this workspace
and my role is noted as admin
and on the right hand side you can see a
bunch of options so let's drill down
into those
the first thing that you might want to
think about is how
are you going to invite students into
your class
unfortunately there isn't just yet
um an easy way to like upload a roster
for example of student emails so
what my recommendation would be is
instead of choosing invitation
require where you would have to actually
uh individually invite each one of your
students especially if you're teaching a
larger class i would recommend setting
the access option to
shared um but do so for a short period
of time
and share this link with your students
and you want to enroll them as
contributors and i will talk about what
the other access levels are in a second
when i say share this link with your
students though
i might recommend if you are worried
about random strangers getting into your
workspace
that that sharing is not necessarily
done in
a um public way so if you keep a
public course website for example
instead of pasting it there
use for example your course management
software or a roster that you have to
email the link to your students
if you don't care about who gets in this
workspace
at that point then it doesn't really
matter how you share it so after initial
round of enrollment
uh this could be a drop or this could be
a couple days if you're having to shift
gears mid semester
switch this over to this access level
over to invitation required
and then going forward you can use
invitations for any other people you
need to add
oftentimes i might have like another
colleague who wants to see how i'm
running things
so i might add them as visitors to my
workspace
so the different permission levels we
saw that my name was listed as
admin i am the owner um and i think that
role admin really
translates to instructor in a teaching
setting
i can do everything i can manage users
view edit and manage all projects
in fact nuke the workspace if i want to
another level is moderator
which in an instructor in an
instructional
sense would uh maybe correspond to a ta
these uh the moderators can view edit
and manage
all projects but they don't really get
to manage users
contributors are what i would say
students they can create edit and manage
only their own projects and a viewer
um usually i use it in a course setting
as an auditor
or a visitor or colleague who might want
to see how things are working
they can only view projects that are
shared with everyone
so under the members that same tab um
we also saw these permission levels and
i would recommend
unchecking all of these so what are they
saying contributors can see the members
list
this is basically saying should your
students be able
to see each other's names if you think
about just your students being able to
see each other's names maybe that's not
a big deal
but um if you are going to potentially
open this course up to the public you
might have concerns
about your students names being publicly
available
so i tend to like to uncheck that box
um contributors can make their projects
visible to all members
if this is for a course that is graded
where you are
expecting that students not share code
with each other
let's not make it easier for them to do
so so you can uncheck that box as well
um contributors can change project
resources so
you can change how much memory is
allocated to certain projects
um this might be something you might
want to check or you might want to
uncheck
i would say especially if you're
teaching introductory students
chances are this is not going to be a
concept they're super comfortable with
anyway
so you can uncheck that you can always
set that level for them
yours yourself later on and ultimately
should viewers like auditors be able to
see the members list and i usually
uncheck that too
the moral of the story here is that you
should think carefully before checking
these boxes
and if you're not sure leave them
unchecked
when you create a new workspace you by
default
can get uh 10 people in there including
yourself
a lot of us teach courses that have more
than 10 students in it
so we have this limit there in order to
keep track of usage levels
so you can actually request more members
on that members tab
um and i would recommend doing so as
soon as you set this up what this means
is that if you're setting this up today
and wanting to teach it tomorrow morning
first thing that might be a little tough
because a human actually needs to
approve this
so put in your request as quickly as
possible
and tell us a bit about what you're
using this space for
we're not denying any requests at this
point this is more for tracking of what
people are using our studio cloud for
so that we can try to anticipate what
the demand levels might be
another very attractive feature of our
studio cloud
if you're using workspaces is this idea
of a base
project so what do i mean by a base
project
in this base project you can the
packages you want installed on students
projects live there
um text documents that you want to
appear on
all student projects also live there i
usually use this for something like a
code of conduct for example or if you
have
specific instructions that um
that are the same from assignment to
assignments you can put in things like
how do you turn in your work there as
well
um any the base project applies to
all projects created after the base
project has been specified
it does not apply retroactively and that
should be an attractive feature once
people create a project in the class
the setting of the settings of that
project shouldn't change
if you later decide to change how your
base project looks
i think most importantly the base
project can be updated as many times as
you like throughout the course
without having to convince any it people
so
there might be a new version of a
package that you want your students to
learn about
and you can choose to install that
package to your base project at 2am the
night before you teach
and tomorrow morning when they get in
and start working on an assignment it'll
be available to them
how does it work to create a base
project um
there are a few steps for it you start
by creating
just like any old project in this base
project you're
going to want to install any packages
that you may
want to have i like renaming the project
right away
as base project you really can use any
name you want
it just needs to be identifiable um so
that you can
choose it from a list later as i said
before i always like creating in our
markdown document because
that list of packages i forget what they
are like all the list of packages you
need to get our markdown up and running
at least our studio does it
automatically for me so even though i'm
not
putting in our markdown document here i
go through the motions of doing so
i like adding a plain text file that is
basically a code of conduct so i would
add some verbiage to that but to keep
things simple
i'll leave it just with a heading for
now this means
this file is going to be carried
copied over to every single project
created
in this workspace um
and then i'm going to want to
make choose this to be my base project
but
i'm showing you something here that i
almost do every single time
which is that before you can make a
project your base
project you need to change its
permissions
to be available to everyone okay so we
want to change the permissions to be
available to everyone
then we click on the gear icon and
select the base project
by name and then if at a later point
you want to edit it you can actually do
so so
say tomorrow you decide to teach a topic
that uses a package
that you haven't used before you can
actually go ahead and
add that package to your base project
and you can see that once a project has
been set as a base
project it disappears from the project
list so now i'm creating a regular
project in my class let's say this is
the homework one assignment that i'm
creating for my students
i can create a template document for
them to start working on
and you will see that as i'm creating
this document
rstudio does not prompt me to install
the packages that are required for our
markdown because those already got
carried over
from my base project if i if this is the
homework assignment i want to give
i'm going to make it available to
everyone and i'm going to check the box
next to make this assignment
make this project an assignment
now that i have set up a base project
and the first homework assignment in my
class it is time for me
to invite my students i go to the
members tab of my workspace
um i click choose shared i say that
initial row for my students should be
contributors and i copy the sharing link
it's going to end up being an awfully
long link you might want to use a link
shortener or something before you email
it to your students it doesn't really
matter
and then your student now receives that
email from you
with the link to the workspace so how do
things look like for your student
they go to that link and this is where
they land
they need to log in and they can use if
they have an
existing google account log in it says
do you want to join the space yes
and they land here with your message
about
this is what this workspace is for and
if they get to the projects they can see
their homework one assignment
and start it so you can see that the our
markdown file you set up for them is
there
the document knits without prompting
students
to install any packages the code of
conduct from the base project is also
there as well
one other thing i will mention is git
integration i said that
git works out of the box for studio
cloud this is only relevant if you're
teaching with git
and github i mean in a teaching context
if it's only relevant if you're teaching
version control as well
um i think the really really attractive
thing is that
your base project templates can be used
which means that when students go and
clone a new project from git
they will get any plain text files that
live in that git repository
but the rstudio cloud project that they
initiate will also have the right
packages installed
so they get the text files that are
going to be version tracked
um from git but they
land them in an r studio environment
that has the right packages with the
right versions and everything you have
set up for them
installed on the other side
a little bit disappointing side at least
for now
if you're teaching with git you need to
introduce yourself to get
once per each project that usually
translates to for each assignment that
you assign to your students for example
which means that at the beginning of
each of your assignments you're probably
going to want to include
uh some instructions like one of the
following if you're happy with your
students using the terminal remember
that the rstudio ide
has a terminal window and they can use
commands like git config username and
git config user email
and run those in the terminal personally
for teaching introductory courses
i try to not land my students in the
terminal as much as possible
so i like the function called use git
config from
uh the use this package which basically
um has runs the same thing that
that it amounts to the same thing as
running the commands in the terminal
except they're doing things in our
studio so things feel a little bit more
familiar
now important thing here is that if
you're going to be
asking students to use to use this
command
you want to make sure that you install
the use this package in your base
package as well
so they're not um they're not going to
have to install it themselves so your
instructions work out of the box
so pros and cons of sharing a workspace
in this manner
on the good side you get these various
permission levels which i think is
really attractive especially if you work
with tas
um the base projects with the desired
packages installed is another attractive
feature
the assignment feature removes the need
to remind students to make a
copy of the project before they start
work so they no longer get that pesky
temporary
project blinking light instead as they
click start for assignments as they
click start on an assignment
our studio cloud automatically makes
that copy for them
and i think most most importantly
especially
for remote teaching this ability to peek
in the student projects is very
attractive
on the not so good side students land in
the workspace
and they may need some instructions to
figure out what they need to do next
because when they land in the uh
workspace
remember they see your workspace name
and your instructions
so you might want to put in your
instruct or your welcome message
something like now click on projects to
find out
your assignments um the get config step
that we just talked about for each
project can get
tedious and i think most importantly it
doesn't reflect realistic practice if
you're running things locally that
config step
is something you would probably do
globally just once on your computer
um i do hope that that's something um
that will change soon and uh
once uh we have a different way of
figuring out how
files are shared at the system level for
each account
um as i mentioned for remote teaching
you now you can easily peek into your
student project so here is a workshop
that i taught
um remotely and i have
projects for each one of the modules in
the workshop
and for i usually like this view in my
workspaces
where you can see on the right hand side
for list projects i only click on yours
which means mine which means i don't
have to see all the copies
that my students have made because if
you have hundreds of students
that list is going to get very long but
it gives me this really nicely organized
view
of the modules or assignments i've given
my students
and i can click on those links that says
view drive projects
and i didn't want to show you the next
step because it would have student names
in there
but then you would be able to see the
projects of every single one of your
students who have made a copy
and then click on it and actually go
into their project so you can see their
code exactly where they left it
which is great for helping them
obviously i think
initially you probably want to get them
to describe to you what the issue is
but things can get a little bit
frustrating especially
if you can't see their screen so this is
an opportunity to actually peek in
and you can also see how many students
or which students actually started their
work if that's something you want to
track at certain points of an assignment
a few common pitfalls using either
paradigm
sharing projects or sharing a workspace
it's important to remember that
when a student makes a copy of your
project
or when they start an assignment our
studio cloud
is making a literal copy of that project
at that
time point so changes you make after a
student launches a project
under either model won't propagate to
their project
this is not like collaborative editing
of google docs it is more like
you distributing handing out paper to
your students and then if you
make changes to your own copy that's not
going to propagate to theirs
what does this mean um until you're
ready to share
an assignment with your students i would
recommend keeping the access level
to be available only to you which is the
default anyway
so you could be working on your what
your next week's homework is going to
look like
um and your students don't need to see
that work until you're ready to actually
make that project available to everyone
another common pitfall that i see is
that packages in the base project
will be installed for everyone but
they will not be loaded so if you need
students to run
code in the console that requires a
package your instructions should remind
them to load the package first so run
something like a library command they
never should need to run
install packages unless that's part of
your learning objective of course
but they do need to run the library
command and also if using in our
markdown document that you're giving
them as a template
you might have a chunk on top that loads
the packages that you want
um how do we get fee
if you have any feedback or questions or
our studio cloud isn't working and you
need some troubleshooting
uh the first thing you can do is you'll
see on the left hand side
um on the menu at the bottom you'll see
a link to system status will
which will take you to
status.rtstudio.com and there you can
see all the hosted services
that our studio runs one of which is our
studio cloud but also things like shiny
apps at i o
as well and if things seem normal there
um then i would recommend and but you
are having difficulty with something
then i would recommend reporting it
because you might be the first person
who is actually
seeing the issue you might also see that
it might be going
uh that rcd cloud might be under active
maintenance or that there is an issue
that's reported
and there's certain levels in the uh
team that works the engineering team
that works on our studio cloud if there
is actually an
outage issue we'll provide details there
so that's really the first place to
check to see
what's up with our studio cloud today
other options if you're having any sort
of
either questions about how to do
something on our studio cloud
or want to report at the issue you can
post on our studio community
um but you can also email support
rstudio.cloud i think the third option
might be especially useful if you are an
instructor and you have to share
something like a link to a student
project so that if there's an issue with
this particular student's work
that the student can't get into it that
may not be something you may want to
share publicly on our studio community
so you're welcome to email support at
our studio cloud with that
um a couple of things that are on the
horizon for our studio cloud
uh we are working towards providing
institution accounts
so this will be especially useful if you
are a person who is maybe a course
organizer for a course that runs with
multiple
sections and you want to be able to
manage them in a centralized fashion
you should be able to do that this is
coming down the pipeline soon
another thing is a dashboard for student
usage and
engagement metrics so you can see on a
monthly basis maybe how many members you
have how many active projects
what the compute units are and you'll be
able to drill down into these more as
well
um and we are also we have a package
actually called r rs cloud that
is uh for managing our studio cloud
spaces with r
it currently um requires an api
key which any instructor can request
currently you need to do that via email
to support at our studio.cloud
but soon you'll be able to do so in the
ui as well
uh some of the attractive features of
this package is that it has
um functions for inviting your students
to your workspace
and stuff like that so you can basically
get to automate
some of those steps um instead of having
to click around in the r studio cloud ui
a few parting remarks i'll start with
some tips
so first of all each project is
allocated one
gig of ram which means that you really
should test things out
before assignments involving especially
large data sets
it's important that you give this a try
and
one of the things where you may not be
able to try is if you have a project
that is involving
um students to go get their own data
sets
um then you kind of can't necessarily
foresee what
whether or not the memory will be
sufficient remember that you can
increase the memory allocation of a
project if you need
but it's important to test things out so
you don't run into kind of
surprising roadblocks in the middle of
teaching
another really important thing is that
what your students see
is not always what you see earlier on in
the slides i had the little icons for
the
teacher view and the student view and we
could see that those look a little bit
different
my strong recommendation for you would
be to create a secondary account with
another
throwaway email address you have and add
that person
that account as a student at the
contributor level
i would recommend logging on from that
account from something like an incognito
window
so that you can test to see what your
students will see
before they actually see it
more tips um i think brief screencasts
for getting students oriented with a
platform
this is especially true if you're remote
teaching and you don't
if you don't have a synchronous
component to your teaching or you won't
be able to you know show things on the
board like you might
uh when you're teaching in person uh i
think is really useful
the screencasts that i showed um during
this webinar
are included in this youtube playlist if
you would like to borrow some of them
many of them are geared towards
instructors but a couple of them were
from the student view so you're welcome
to use those if you would like to do so
another thing that i see very regularly
is that
this is what the r studio cloud window
looks like when you first start and
many of our students work on not huge
screens but something like a 13-inch
laptop or a chromebook that's even
smaller
and so the real estate is really limited
and you have this
sidebar on the left hand side and a lot
of students forget to
x out of that to close it and they lose
a valuable real estate so i would
recommend reminding your students that
they can click on that x next to the
rstudio cloud
logo and the sidebar will go away that
will
extend their r studio ide screen so they
have a little bit more
room to play with um
finally read the rstudio cloud guide
um inevitably this webinar is going to
get a little bit out of date
as our studio cloud evolves but the rcdo
cloud guide
um that is linked from the sidebar as
well is
going to be the most up-to-date
information on
how our studio cloud works because the
engineering team adds to that
um as they build more features out
on the rstudio cloud website on the
sidebar you'll also
see a link to the primers these are
learn our tutorials
that the our studio education team has
put together
these are free um to use and they are
basically a companion to
the r for data science book by garrett
broliman and hadley wickham
so if there are certain things that you
want to offload your teaching to
to uh tutorials others have prepared
before you might be able to see valuable
materials here
um they don't actually use our studio
cloud
right now they're just learn our
tutorials that are hosted on shiny apps
that i o
but they're easily accessible from the
rstudio cloud screen
and finally um our studio cloud is in
beta so
um it continues to evolve
and we are you know working on making
sure that it's really
reliable and available um if you have
any questions the place to go
is our studio community and for now our
studio cloud
is currently free to use and as we learn
what it costs to operate
uh the service and how it's used by the
community there will be
a paid plan available for it as well but
for the time being it's free to use um
so you can go ahead and start set up
your clouds there
tomorrow if you want thank you very much
for listening in and i'd be happy to
answer any questions now
so one of the questions says by any
chance uh does our studio cloud
integrate well with moodle
currently there is no specific
learning management system integration
with our studio cloud
but this is certainly um in the
pathway for development because we know
that this is something instructors are
going to want
um so what does this mean that means
that
currently there is not a way for you to
get
all your students that might be on
moodle or any other learning system
management system use with your
university directly into an rstudio
cloud workspace
but as i said as long as you're able to
reach out to them
you can share the workspace link with
them obviously it's a manual step but
that's how you can get them in
the next thing probably is submission of
work
if you are using a learning management
system it is very likely
that you will ultimately want your
students to submit their work
there um so what i would recommend doing
is once
student do their students do their work
on our studio cloud
they can actually export out any files
using the files pane
in the r studio ide check the boxes for
any files they want to submit
click on more and then export that will
create a zipped folder that they can
upload to their learning management
system
when it comes to actually grading their
work
you may want to choose with what they
submitted there or you may want to
simply go into their projects on our cdo
cloud that's entirely up to you
but if you want an official record of
submission
that's what i would recommend doing
let's see could we download the slides
yes you can actually go to the
link and get the slides while they're
made with sure engine so they are
um html slides
can the student also have the workspace
open when me
instructor peeks into their workspace
okay so that's a really good question
and i will
start by um some terminology there so
the workspace is your
classroom and what your student is
working on
is a project and it's a project that
you're peeking into
so can you be peeking into that project
while the student also has the project
open
um it actually does kick them out it
doesn't necessarily crash their session
per se but it kicks them out briefly
and so let me tell you how i like using
this usually i don't just peek into
student projects
without um us getting to a point in the
conversation where i feel like that's
going to be needed
i try to encourage students on a
discussion forum that we use for course
q a
to try to describe the problem that they
have as well as possible
but if it comes to the point where i
feel like i need to look in
i tell them that i'm about to go into
your workspace you may want to save your
files
not that not them not saving the files
will be an issue but students get
worried if they get kicked out
with unsaved files so i remind them to
do so
and then peek into their workspace and
then let them know again when i
get out of there on the online
discussion forum or wherever we're
conversing
um that this is what i'm doing another
way i've used this
is actually um on a synchronous call
something like a zoom call for example i
tell the student okay this is i'm going
to go into that it's going to kick you
out
but they can actually watch me work in
their
project and see what changes i've made
to debug the issue that they were having
what's the process for sharing data
files just load them into the workspace
um so the process for sharing data files
is you load them into the project you
create a new project
that is going to be an exercise or an
assignment your students are working on
and using the files pane in the
rstudio ide you can upload any files
directly into there
a file size constraint so i think the
issue
more so than file size constraints is
the memory
um so you may want to think about not
just your
data file size but what you're going to
be do with
to be doing with it if you are simply
running you know depart commands
a lot large data file is not going to be
an issue
but if you're going to be running
bootstrap like bootstrap sampling on
that
uh on a large data frame with many rows
and doing so over tens of thousands of
times then that might actually be an
issue
and that's why i mentioned you may want
to test out what it is that you want to
do in terms of the assignment
how do you load a data set or existing
files into the cloud so i think this is
that same
question so on the files pane
um there is a button that says upload
and that's how you do that
um can we run code chunks in
python or c um
the answer should be yes
it's running the r studio ide so yes you
can
run python chunks i'm fairly certain
this is true
now i have to test that out
um you said that sharing a project with
students
there are two main ways in the first way
they have to make a copy of the project
in order to not to lose the changes
can you show how to do this so let's go
back
uh real quick so this is the student
view
of the project so
let's go to the very beginning of this
your student comes to the project that
you shared with them
um they log on and i'm going to pause
the screen when i need to in a second
so over here they can see that
the project is temporary and this is
blinking
and next to it they can see a button
that says save a permanent copy
when they click on save a permanent copy
that blinking temporary project is going
to go away
and what that does at that instance is
it makes a copy of that project that
places them into their
own like personal workspace that i call
the sandbox at the beginning of the
presentation
another question i had a problem with
our studio connect
our studio cloud to connect it to
relational databases
um okay i i
let's leave that question out to the um
our studio community discussion thread
that we'll have
available for this because i don't know
off the top of my head
as i haven't tried this myself before in
my teaching
so i'm going to hold off on answering
the question about using our studio
cloud and relational databases
another question is i assume the
students can download files locally as
typically they will need to submit
assignments in the lms that's absolutely
correct they can download the files
using the files pane check the boxes
next to the files that they want to
download
click on more and then export which will
export them out as a zip file
which i find is an attractive feature
because then they simply need to upload
that zip file onto your learning
management system
some of the learning management systems
i've worked with in the past
sometimes don't like certain extensions
like html
or our markdown they may not know what
it is but usually are okay with zip
folders so
it doesn't matter how you have them what
you have them knit their files to
usually a zipped file upload is
something that an lms
accepts
do i need a separate space for each
group of students if i have more than
one
so i think this depends on what you mean
by
group if the students are all exposed to
the same material in the class
and the same assignments at that point
you should not need
separate spaces even if they're saying
different workshop groups or something
however if you have more than one
classes that you're teaching
so these are going to be separate
content for each of the classes separate
assignments
you probably don't want to confuse the
students
with assignments for another class in
which case you would need to have
separate workspaces is it possible to
correct homeworks
automatically or do we need to visualize
students answers
there is no built-in auto grading
that is built into our studio cloud if
you are
interested in doing auto grading with
work with r
i think the most promising thing and you
need this student
code to be run i suppose uh the most
promising thing i can think of is if you
teach with version control
you can have your students push their
work to a github repository
and you could run continuous integration
tools like github actions on it
to provide um instant feedback to the
students or to do auto grading
this is not necessarily a fully solved
problem just yet
but that seems to be the most um kind of
doable option for going forward on that
uh but in terms of
grading student work on our studio cloud
your option is to go into their project
and start working through it
or you have them submit the output file
through some other means and then you
simply evaluate the output file it
depends on
what it is that you are evaluating them
on
it seems like we do not need to request
anything if you're if our group is under
25 students
um if your group
is under 10 students you do not need to
request anything otherwise by default
in a workspace you can only have up to
10 students or i guess 9 students
because
one of the seats is taken by you
um another question is from uh somebody
who's teaching intro to deep learning
course
and it looks like it could solve a lot
of issues if
we have um six years
to use our studio cloud but they will
probably need substantial computation
time is there anything i should take
into account specifically on the
computation side of things in our studio
cloud
so i think this is where we come to the
memory conversation here so you are
probably going to need to request
higher memory limits and that's
something that what i would recommend
that you do
is create a workspace put some of your
materials
in a project within that workspace try
running through it
and see what's choking and if it is the
case that the memory allocated by
default the one gig is not sufficient
then i would reach out to support
rstudio.cloud
to describe your use case um i know
that we have so that would require an
increased memory limit so that's
something that you're going to need to
request ahead of time
thank you so much